[Music]
well i love painting a mask because it
gets me out in weather like this
it's pretty awesome to come into a
resort and look up and see mind map
[Music]
james nehews and i've painted ski maps
of some of the biggest resorts around
the world
i've painted 194
different maps
this is north star out of lake tahoe new
mexico ski area we have snow basin here
utah
this is an image that skiers see they
judge the mountain by the trail map you
want to portray the mountain as
beautiful as it is
i was a advertising agency man for a
while
in 1987 i uh painted my first trail map
yeah they used my map
i loved it right away i could paint and
do a little travel and learn how to
skate
whenever i get a call from a resort
first thing that i'll do is scoop out
the mountain and see what i've got to
work with
i work heavily from aerial photography
i'll go up in a plane and take a paint
across the whole mountain in a shot
from this i take it back to the studio
and i get on my computer and select the
ones that i want to work from print them
out and then i reference all the
material that i can get and start my
sketch
what i will have to do is manipulate the
different elements of the mountain and
get it on a single plane of paper on a
single page
what i like to do is show the skier what
he's skiing through they help the skier
identify where he is on the mountain
for a large ski resort it'll take me
three weeks of painting but that doesn't
include all your prep work so
realistically it'll take me three months
do i have a favorite mountain wow
i've done a lot of them and a lot of
really exciting mountains
there's a lot of things that i love
about doing this job i get to fly in
some of the most beautiful spots in the
world
i'm going to keep doing this as long as
i can
[Music]
you